[Music]
hello everyone
i'm pleased today really quite pleased
to have dr lawrence krauss with me
he is an internationally known
theoretical physicist and i've wanted to
talk to an internationally known
theoretical physicist for about 30 years
whose research is focused on the
interface between elementary particle
physics and cosmology
including the fundamental structure of
matter and the evolution of the universe
among his numerous important and
interesting scientific contributions
was his 1995 proposal
that most of the energy of the universe
resided in empty space
during his career professor krause has
held endowed professorships and
distinguished
research appointments at major
institutions all over the world
including harvard yale and cern he is
the author of 500 publications and 11
popular books
including the international bestsellers
the physics of star trek
and a universe from nothing his most
recent book
the physics of climate change was
released in february of this year
2021 he won a major award from all three
of the u.s national physics societies
as well as the 2012 public service award
from the national science board
for his contributions to the public
understanding of science
he currently serves as president of the
origins
project foundation which celebrates
science and culture
by connecting scientists artists writers
and celebrities
with the public through special events
online discussions
and unique travel opportunities the
foundation produces
the origins podcast featuring dialogues
with some of the most interesting people
in the world
discussing issues that address the
global challenges of the 21st century
thank you very much for agreeing to talk
to me today it's great to be with you
virtually
jordan okay so i have a question and i'm
going to jump right into it i wrote a
paper
with a couple of my students i was the
final author on the paper um we were we
tried to relate
the experience of anxiety to a physical
property to
to entropy which i suppose might be well
defined as a physical property
the idea was so and you tell me what you
think of this as a physicist if you
would
okay the idea was that human beings are
always trying to calculate a path from
one point to another
and the the length of the path is going
to be proportionate in some sense to the
energy
used to undertake the task
right the longer the path the more
energy now we generally take a path to
something that we regard as valuable and
sources of energy for example are
extremely valuable to us and so that
might be a shortcut to doing some work
because that's translatable into goods
anyways the cost of the voyages
is is an important consideration and so
whenever uncertainty is added to a
plan the it becomes more and more
difficult to formulate a map that
lays out the trajectory appropriately
and you need a marker for that a
psychological marker
and so we assume that as the certainty
of the path that you're you're
going to take according to you know get
given a particular reward is as the
uncertainty that increased
you'd experience this unease and the
unease was a marker of the increased
complexity
so and that would be the increased
entropy in some sense
of either of the landscaper of your
representation of the landscape or maybe
of the disjunction between the two
so the first question i would have is is
i guess first of all was that a
comprehensible explanation and second of
all is that a reasonable way of
construing entropy
well yeah um okay the answer is it's not
unreasonable
in a general sense i i do where i'm very
wary
i remember you know when i was a kid
actually in canada and i took i remember
i was always interested in science but i
in university i took sociology
and i remember becoming fascinated at
the time by various sociologists
attempts
to define concepts as if borrow from
physics to
define concepts and i thought wow this
is fascinating
as i as i got to know more physics i
became more wary
of of that application because certain
things that are well defined and
appropriate in physical context
become less well-defined and perhaps
have less utility
they sound good in in a social science
paper but whether they actually allow
predictive value is
is the important question right and so
that's exactly why i'm asking the
question isn't yet because i'm sure i'm
aware of that problem and that's i
wanted to
see if there's some bedrock there well
you know i think that there
you it's i think you've got something in
a sense that
in physics actually in different
contexts there's trade-offs between
energy and entropy
and difference and and and um and
they're well-defined thermodynamic
quantities that
that that are are defined depending upon
what you hold fixed and what and what
you don't and how the system evolves
whether it evolved to assist assist uh
situation of
least energy or at least what's called
free energy which depends
or enthalpy which which includes that
entropy
aspect depends upon the specific
circumstances of the physical situation
but that that the complexity of a path
is related to the entropy is is is a
really
is an approach that is appropriate
because entropy
really describes uh and maybe it's
probably useful for your listeners who
may not be as aware of entropy as you
are
that what it really describes is a
macroscopic system
has many different internal states it
can be in
and entropy really just describes how
many internal states
a system has for a given macroscopic
configuration of
of say temperature and overall energy
you know a single particle in this in in
a box may have a a restricted
configuration but the atoms in my body
and your body
can be in very many different
configurations and still be at the same
temperature so there's a lot of
entropy associated with with a with a
macroscopic object
and the more if you wish the more
internal possibilities that a system has
to explore within the
confines of some external parameter
that's restricting it like the total
energy of the
system or its heat content or or
or some other aspect or its volume the
more internal
configurations the system has to explore
the bigger its entropy
so now okay so i was thinking for
example i'll give you a narrative
example
it's actually apropos because my car did
break down today but
when you're in your car and you're
driving along
and everything is going according to
your desires and expectations
then you're generally in a low anxiety
state
but then imagine that the car emits an
unexpected noise and starts to buck
now one of the things i've proposed is
that at that point you're actually no
longer in a car
and that's why you get upset because the
car is actually functionally described
as a category the car is something that
gets you from point a to b
and as long as it's performing that
function then that category was a very
low resolution category
that category suffices but as soon as
something goes wrong same thing happens
when your computer does something you
don't want it to
there's so many different states that
that thing could be
in that your body signals that that
emergent complexity and it signals the
fact that you can no longer compute the
cost of being where you are
and you know there's fantasies that are
associated with that that seem like
attempts to map it right
like this could be wrong this could be
wrong i might go to a crooked mechanic i
might get ripped off i might not be able
to fix this car maybe i can't afford it
i won't get to work
like the whole the whole panoply of
possibility
expands very very suddenly and that
produces
in an intense physiological response
which it should do i mean we should have
physiological responses to fundamental
physical realities
we should most of us ignore them and i
think that's the point
the physiological response you're
talking about is real but in fact when
the car is operating well
all of those possibilities also exist
you just block them out of your mind
i mean because right well that's but
that's an interesting thing too right
because
but it's appropriate in some sense we
were trying to understand to some degree
the conditions under which it's
appropriate to block them under
out of your mind and it's something like
as long as your predictions but they're
based on your desires but we won't get
into that as long as your predictions
match the ongoing
uh flow of events then you can take
all of the presuppositions that order
things for granted
i mean i agree with you completely that
all those things could be going wrong at
any time
the same is true of of the complexity of
your body right i mean
it isn't necessarily the case that just
because you feel good right now you're
going to feel
good the next moment and there's an
endless number of things that can go
wrong but but it's also not helpful to
be aware of all of those possibilities
if they're not likely to happen so it
isn't exactly that you ignore them it's
that you
assume their functional significance is
zero as long as your
plan is operative and well
yeah but i think you know it goes back
to the human reason being the slave of
passion
i think the point is we we you're right
it's it's not worthwhile assuming all
the negative things that can happen if
it did you wouldn't do anything
right if you want to take any action if
you assume all the negative things that
could result from it you probably
wouldn't act at all
one of the things that i think we do and
one of the problems we have as a society
in fact it's related to even my last
book is that
is that we tend one of the things that
science does
which i think is so useful is it
quantifies uncertainty
uncertainty is a central part of science
and often too often
journalists and other people talk about
uncertainty as if it's a bad thing
in science it's actually a very good
thing because we can say we can
define we can quantitatively say how
accurate our result is or how
how likely or unlikely a bunch of
possibilities are i think
psychologically and that i would say
that's an anxiety reduction
phenomena i mean when you enter into a
contract you're doing that with someone
too
because what you're saying is well i
could be any number of possibilities but
contractually i'll limit myself to this
manifestation
and that can make you calm and it can
make us able to cooperate and so
i i think that it's not only a
scientific theory that provides that
function it's a
it's a science would be what a subset of
practical theory
and practical theories they're very
useful exactly for that reason
they are but i think i personally think
more people would could be
i think it would be a better uh it would
help people if they accepted the
existence of a certainty most
you know in a in a more open way i think
we
we people are afraid of of uncertainty
and i think if we you know including
death and the universe and all sorts of
other things we may talk about
and i think um accepting it as a
realistic likelihood
is a is a healthy thing because
again it relates to some extent to some
of the i think social problems that are
happening now of kids being coddled
if you accept that bad things can happen
then it when you do any you know it's
part of living
then you won't be so anxious when they
do i think i mean you won't be so
fearful
of of that possibility okay yeah your
car can break down but the world isn't
over
you know there's a whole series of of
other activities you can take place
that will allow the world to go on that
will allow you to continue to function
but recognizing it recognizing at some
level
a spectrum of possibilities in advance
in my opinion and i'm not a psychologist
but in my opinion certainly personally i
i find it psychologically helpful
yeah well you do it is definitely the
case that that's
promoted among psychologists i mean
behavioral psychologists you may imagine
that
one thing you want is a theoretical
configuration that encapsulates
uncertainty
that's a belief system let's say and and
you measure it by its functional utility
does it allow you to to acquire what you
desire when you act it out
but you need a codicil along with that
which is well what do you do when your
theory goes wrong
and one of the answers that's been
provided to that question from
the behavioral perspective it's coded in
narrative as well though is
uh approach uncertainty voluntarily and
cautiously
don't avoid it and that triggers another
mechanism which is the capacity to
explore
to generate new theories to select among
them especially in
what in in collaboration with other
people and to regenerate your
pre-existing models
so you need the model and you need a
system for updating the model and i see
you see that expressed in
pretty formally in science in the
scientific technique
oh it's a central part of the scientific
method and i would also argue in
business and many other areas of human
activity that people don't realize
science what i try and convince people
of they don't realize that scientists
actually really like to be wrong
at least you know and whether personally
they do it's a different question but
the process of science it's exciting to
be wrong
because it means there's more to learn
first of all
and it might mean you discovered
something it means
it often means you've discovered
something and one of the things
you know i was chairman of the physics
department for a long time and and then
we started a program
uh a master's degree in in physics
entrepreneurship
which the business school dean said was
an oxymoron but i don't think so because
i think scientists and business people
are very similar because often
what i realize we don't do well enough
for children
for students or whatever is teach them
how to fail effectively
we give them problem sets that they're
guaranteed that have direct answers and
they can get the correct and we even
give them phds
where they're more or less guaranteed to
at least come to some collusion but in
the real world of research
and business and many other things you
may find that
you have to learn how well the question
i was asking was really not a good
question how can i use what i've already
accumulated
to nevertheless provide me something
useful maybe ask a different question
and go around and so i think the
training training to fail effectively
namely to
find that the thing you were trying to
show is wrong but nevertheless
the process by which you discover that
is very useful
and can be useful somewhere else is is a
central part of science but i actually
think it's probably very useful again in
real life and i think most business
people
you know when i when i learned about
entrepreneurs i asked i asked that
physicists would become
entrepreneurs what they hadn't learned
and it was just that how to fail
effectively because
often startups you know well-known
entrepreneurs have a three or four or
five startups that have failed before
they get to where they're going and i
think
but it's the same of any researcher in
your research i'm sure as in mine
there have been many false starts many
many roadblocks many times when you just
discover hey this problem is really not
amenable to being solved but maybe i can
ask a slightly different question so
i think um being aware
being less anxious of of the fact that
your
planned trajectory is not going to go
where you took it is actually a
wonderful part of life
as a as a again as a scientist
i often say when i write you know you
probably have this problem too you know
you write grant proposals and you write
some
fiction of what you're going to be
studying in three years and my
i always say that if i'm really doing
what i thought i was going to be doing
in three years it's pretty boring
because what i really hope will happen
is i'll be looking at something
completely different because some new
discovery will have come up either
from the outside world of experiment or
from something i'm doing
well is it is it reasonable to ask you
can you remember times when that
specifically happened in your career
where you had to reconfigure and and you
discovered something that was
that was worthwhile as a consequence of
it oh yeah
yeah it's hard to imagine when it hasn't
happened in some sense i think the
well let me give you an example the the
the one you mentioned the discovery that
the
the energy of empty space is the
dominant energy of the universe
i was um
i was studying cosmology and and of
course and the amazing thing about
cosmology is it's over the last 30 years
turned from
or 40 years from an art to a science um
you i think people used to say
cosmologists were never right but never
in doubt
and uh and and and but wonderfully
what's happened because science is an
empirical
discipline is that all new whole new
data sets were coming on new machines
and new telescopes
which were allowing you to make
precision tests of the universe and
therefore derive models that could be
disproved which is really the
central part of science and when i was
trying to understand and i've been
working on on the subject called dark
matter for many years how to detect it
the fact that the
most of the mass in our galaxy in all
galaxies appears to not shine and
and now we're reasonably certain it's
made of some elementary particle that's
different than the particles that make
you and i
up it's a fascinating thing and i've
spent a lot of my career thinking about
it
but one of the reasons we became
confident
that that was the case that these
particles this dark matter was not made
of protons and neutrons and the same
stuff as you and i
was because we built cosmological models
and we found that if this dark matter
was just snowballs or
you know or something that you couldn't
see then plugging them into our models
you couldn't
get a universe that looked like what we
look like today starting from a
hot big bang you couldn't form galaxies
there wasn't enough time
and so dark matter it turns out if dark
matter doesn't interact with light
it it it it's easier for it to collapse
early on in the history of the universe
and that
gives a jump start to galaxies and et
cetera et cetera et cetera
so we're trying to come up with a model
that really was an agreement with
observation
the problem was the observations
ultimately weren't in agreement with
that model
and so the question then becomes
do you know what what do you do and so
i was reasonably convinced at the time
that the
that the reason that was the case that
some of the observations are wrong
which is also something very important
to realize in science is that if they're
many different observations likely some
of them are wrong
and again too often journalists don't
hit on that fact you know they
concentrate on this
one exciting observation which is likely
to be wrong and when it's later on shown
to be wrong they never report on it
and that's part of the problem but so i
i basically was convinced that some of
these key observations were wrong
because they're very difficult
and so somewhat heretically i made this
proposal
i look look there was a colleague of
mine at university of chicago and i
spent a year or two looking at at all
the data
and saying how could it be consistent
with with with what we
with dark matter and and and what would
be required
and the answer was if none of the
observations are wrong
then it looks to us it looked to me at
the time like you'd have to
have most of the energy in the universe
reside in literally nothing
because it what observations weren't
consistent with
with the picture otherwise and i was
convinced at the time
that the reason i was doing that was
just so that people could focus on which
observations were wrong
and so they could see that because the
result because the proposition was so
ridiculous
that empty space actually weighs
something you get rid of all the
particles
and radiation everything that's there
and yet empty space weighs something
that seems so crazy
that surely it's wrong and there must be
well it seems to violate the very pre
the very presupposition that enables us
to identify
mass i mean mass by definition appears
to be something
well mass but mass is different than
energy okay and
and energy and and if you put energy in
empty space it's very and
einstein realized this if you put energy
in empty space
it behaves very differently than it does
if you put energy and matter like
particles in fact what general
relativity tells us
is that mass isn't the key part that
produces gravity
it's energy so there's this relationship
between energy
and gravity and energy in different
forms
produces different types of
gravitational attraction and in fact
that's
relevant to the history of the universe
early on in the history of the universe
most of the energy in the universe
resided in radiation
hot stuff like particles of light moving
at the speed of light
they gravitate very differently than if
most of the energy in the universe
resides in planets or galaxies you know
matter that's
still and so the expansion of the
universe which is gravity's response to
to the presence of energy is different
early on in the history of the universe
when it's dominated by radiation
is that later is that one of the things
that contributes to the rapid inflation
at the beginning
well in fact it's not quite you're
almost there it turns out rapid
inflation happens
if at very early times in the history of
the universe
empty space gets energy empty
because it turns out if for some reason
you
you empty space gets stuck
and somehow it possesses energy even if
in the case of inflation eventually it's
going to release it
in a hot big bang if that energy gets
stuck in empty space
empty space carries with it this
property we call energy
that energy is gravitationally repulsive
not attractive that's the key difference
between energy when you put it in matter
and when you put it in nothing okay so
you said you said a couple of things
that i want to follow up and
okay so and maybe you can take us back
so you said in the last 25 years that
cosmology has transformed itself from an
art to a science
and so maybe you could tell us the
science let's go back to the beginning
14 billion years and walk through it and
because i'm sure that
well i certainly don't understand the
role of dark matter or anything about
dark matter and
i kind of had some sense of what the
current cosmological theories were 20
years ago but i really don't know what
they are now so
let's go back 14 billion years and start
at the beginning if you don't mind
sure we'll try and spend less than 14
million years in describing it
but okay by the way before we get there
let me just end the last story by saying
we made this crazy proposal because
we're sure the experiments are wrong it
turned out
the experiments were right and the
craziness was true and no no one was
more surprised
by it than me that this proposal that
the energy of empty space
dominates the energy of the universe was
right it was just incredibly surprising
it was so surprising eventually
the observers who who confirmed that
fact won the nobel prize uh 10 year
11 years later well in your book the
greatest story ever told so far you
document a very a large number of cases
where
theoretical physicists were driven to
posit something they regarded as
completely absurd
because it seemed to fit the data
assuming that something was wrong and
were later shown to be right even
though they wouldn't necessarily accept
that themselves
yeah exactly in fact uh in fact um um
one of the one of the um uh founders of
of quantum mechanics uh uh
a uh dirac who's a very interesting man
uh psychologically among other things
once said his equation was smarter than
he was because he developed this
equation and he
it predicted this new particle in nature
antimatter and he didn't believe it and
he said it was equation and it turned
out to be true but anyway let's
let's go back to the beginning and um
and well when we go back to the
beginning this is an important
difference between
in my mind science and say religion when
i go back to being i go
back to as far as i can extrapolate my
understanding of the laws of physics
back
before that almost anything goes and
science
we can make and part of my job as a
theoretical physicist was make
speculations
but to recognize that they were just
that and look for signatures that might
suggest whether those speculations were
right or wrong so for example
i actually wrote a book called adam
which takes you back to the
for an individual oxygen atom from the
beginning of the universe to the end one
that's in your
glass of water that you're drinking
right now or during this
podcast um and i i took it back to not
t equals zero because literally we don't
know what happened at t equals zero
because the laws of physics
as we understand the breakdown because
the universe if we extrapolate it back
our universe becomes infinitely dense
and that seems crazy and the laws of
gravity don't work with quantum
mechanics so we really
can talk a lot about it but we
it's not more than talk in my opinion
right now but
but very shortly thereafter uh
after that time um there's no reason to
suspect that the current laws of physics
don't describe what happened in the
history of the universe and again so as
soon as it comes into being
the laws come into being as well yeah
well in fact in
in the universe or nothing i suggested
that's certainly a possibility
maybe they pre-existed maybe they don't
those that you those are metaphysical
questions but
but what i did show in that book which
is fascinating to me and the fact that
30 years ago we wouldn't even been able
to ask the question much less answer it
is that it's quite likely that our
universe could and did
spontaneously arise out of nothing no
space no time and maybe no laws
and if you ask what would be the
properties of a universe
today 14 billion years later that arose
from nothing spontaneously without any
supernatural shenanigans
the properties of that universe would be
precisely the properties of the universe
we
observe now that doesn't prove that's
the case that just makes it plausible
but to me
that's a fascinating thing and again we
never 30 years ago we didn't have the
tools to even
in some sense ask that question but very
we're still estimating the the birth of
about 14 billion years ago
13.8 yeah now if you actually look at
the numbers which we can measure
we now know that number 13.8 to an
accuracy of
you know plus or minus of maybe a few
100 million years or two
13.75 i think is the most recent number
and it's amazing
the fact that you can get beyond one
decimal place in cosmology
is just remarkable and i really it
really is a testament to the
developments when i was
even a young assistant professor at yale
um
i remember talking to an older colleague
who said that nature would always
conspire so that we could never measure
the fundamental quantities of the
universe
better than within a factor of two
because that's always been the case up
to that point every time
someone claimed to have a better
measurement you'd go out and look at
astrophysical uncertainties and realize
it was wrong
and now we're talking about measuring
things to four or five or six decimal
places it's really
it's it's it's really a transformation
and one we're celebrating which is what
i tried to do in that book
but but the early picture that the fact
that we evolved from a big bang is
it is not in dispute let me make that
clear the big bang happened
just like the just like evolution
happened and the earth is round and all
the other things we know it
there's no doubt that we be uh that the
early history of the universe was a hot
big bang
now so and in fact everything we now see
all you know ever all the galaxies we
now see
and all the particles in those galaxies
the 100 billion stars in each galaxy
the 100 billion galaxies all of that
material was contained in a region
smaller than the size of a single atom
and that's just so
okay let me ask you a question about
that sure i mean
is it reasonable to conceptualize
something like that as having a size
because we're we're considering size
within the universe and it's almost
when you say that the universe at the
beginning had a size it's like it was an
object in a universe that had a size but
it's a really good question and i i
should be clearer in my language
the universe could be infinite i want to
ask
as a physicist and and wheeler would
have liked this einstein certainly that
operational questions i don't know how
big the universe is whether it's infor
not but what i do know is
how big is the visible universe so if i
ask you
how big was the region which now
comprises the visible universe today
at an earlier time that that has a good
that's that's well defined
that region the size of an atom could
have existed in a universe which was
infinite even then there could have been
it could have been an infinitely dense
universe that was infinitely big
okay so all we can ask and this is
really a big change also from when i was
a student
we ne because we used to when i was a
kid or when i even
a student we talk about universe and
universe would mean everything
that kind of ill-defined quantity
everything what is the heck is
everything
now we're much more well-defined we say
our universe
a good definition of our universe is
that region
with which we could have interacted
in the past and with which we will be
able to
interact into the future even if the
future is infinitely long
and that may not be everything right
that could be just a small region of a
much bigger thing which we now call a
multiverse
so so it's reasonable to describe our
universe as that region into which we
could have had causal contact namely
which
which cause could have produced effect
right and
and if there's any region outside of it
which we can never affect or be affected
by
that might as well not be considered
part of our universe that distance that
causal
causally interactable distance that's
defined
or limited by the speed of light the
speed of light and the age of the
universe
so for example in the early history of
the universe that's called the horizon
in analogy with the earth when you look
out at the earth you can you know when
it curves you can only see out to a
certain distance and
and we call the causal horizon that
region with which light could have
traveled to interact with us since the
beginning of time
right and and that's the universe as far
as we're concerned because nothing
outside of that can affect us in any way
exactly
so operationally it's a much better
definition of a universe to be that
which we can be causally affected by
and so and and and because that that
changes with time that's
that's what is our observable universe
changes with time and we'll get to it
because things have changed a lot in
in the last so is that does that mean
that our are the universe that causely
affects us is
we're at the center of it no well we're
well actually yes and no
we're always at the center of our own
universe right i mean
psychologically because that's well well
but because of the
causality argument that you just laid
out it seems to imply that directly
because well it certainly does in the
sense that
if if you want to think of it and that
this is one of the confusions that
many confusions which i may add to
during this podcast
but we'll try not to is that you know
when we look out at this thing called
the cosmic microwave background
radiation
it's it's a residual radiation left over
from the hot big bang
and it comes from a sphere if you wish
that's located with us at the center
because it
it it early on in history universe when
it was hot and dense
light interacted with matter and
basically it followed a you know
a random walk it wasn't free to travel
because all the universe was charged and
light would interact and bounce off
things
but at a certain point when the universe
was about 300 000 years old
matter became neutral protons captured
electrons to form hydrogen for the most
part
and neutral matter doesn't interact with
light as strongly as charged particles
and that meant that that radiation which
was kind of trapped
early on when the universe was 300 000
years old could suddenly travel
through freely through the universe
without really interacting
and when we look out basically we see
space and we
and the light you know can travel and
travel travel but if we're looking back
further in time when we look out
and if we look out in that direction
back to a time when the universe was 300
000 years old
we're kind of sort of going to see a
wall if you wish because
we can't see before that time because
the light you know couldn't have
propagated out just like it can't
propagate out through a wall
only from the surface of the wall can we
see it and of course so
when i look at the microwave background
from earth i'm looking if you wish at
the sphere
located almost 13 well actually it's
because the expansion universe it's more
than it's about 26 billion
light years in each direction because
the universe has expanded during the
time that the
light has been traveling but don't worry
about that that
complexity we're looking at a sphere
located a certain let's say
20 10 to 20 billion years light years
away from us in all directions
and we literally can't see beyond that
but the sphere we're looking at depends
upon where we are so that if we were
doing the same experiment on intelligent
species in another galaxy
located 100 million light years away
the the literally the cosmo microwave
background that they would see
would be slightly different because
they'd be sent it'd be a sphere centered
on different places
and that's why actually the the
predictions we can make in some sense as
cosmologists
are somewhat statistical because we're
talking about a thermal distribution
and galaxies and lots of disorder and so
the picture and we've taken pictures of
the microwave background it's won at
least two nobel prizes for those
pictures
the picture that we see has statistical
properties
which would be identical to those
observed by another observer 100
million light years away but the
specifics the hot spots on the cold
spots would be different
because they'd be looking at a at a
different
slice of a statistical distribution sure
okay okay so
so that does correct me if i'm wrong
that does seem to imply that
so the universe is a globe around us
let's see our visible universe
our visible universe sorry i want to be
precise with my words too and so
i move halfway across the universe and
the globe is still there but now it's
shifted
that far and so then i could move
another halfway and it would shift again
so this globe moves with
with the observer so to speak
and that certainly seems to imply that
it extends beyond the globe that we
see because if you move it it moves
so and exactly well and it wouldn't if
there was some edge but there's no
evidence of any edge
okay i think that the point is that um
even before the weirdness of of empty
space and inflation
we was recognized that the part of the
universe we see is unlikely to be the
everything there is we're limited in
what we can see because
of what's seeable just like being on
earth and it's
limited because of the speed of light
and and the age of the universe but also
because of the
way the universe was constituted in its
early stages and the way it's expanded
and the way it's expanded ever since
let me throw in a wrinkle if that was
clear now let me
muddy it okay because it used to be
again sensible when i even in my early
spirit as a scientist
that the we'd assume the longer the
older the universe
the longer we live the older the
universe is the more we'll be able to
see
right because light can travel further
the universe is expanding but it we
thought at the time that that expansion
was slowing down and therefore
the the longer we wait the more we'll
see
because light from further and further
objects can get to us
what's really crazy now is because we
recognize that apparently
empty space is dominating the energy of
the universe
that's causing the universe to expand
ever faster
faster and faster and faster and what it
means
is there are parts of the universe that
are literally escaping from our site
there are parts of the universe
that we that we will never be able to
see and moreover
even more so there are parts of our
universe that we could see now
that if we were a civilization that
developed five billion years from now in
real telescopes that we couldn't see
then
because regions of the universe are
eventually moving away from us faster
than the speed of light
and and are now invisible so the longer
we wait the less we'll see
because more and more galaxies will be
literally disappearing behind the
horizon
the longer we wait i i wrote some papers
about that
and once a scientific american article
and i think some of my books that
eventually the far future of the
universe i know we said we'd start of
the past but the far future is kind of
poetic
because up till about 1925
the picture of the universe was quite
natural based on
observation one galaxy we saw one galaxy
the milky way galaxy
okay and beyond that it was assumed to
be eternal
empty dark space that just was static
and edwin hubble who was famous for
discovering the universe was expanding
did something before that in 1925
he first realized that in fact there
were other galaxies
that these things called nebulae in our
galaxy with the new
hundred inch telescope and mount wilson
could be discerned and be seen as other
island universes
so already that was a revolution in our
picture of the universe suddenly
our galaxy wasn't all there was there
were other galaxies and then of course
later on he discovered the expansion
universe
the interesting thing is that observers
who evolve and there'll still be stars
and say
even up to 10 trillion years from now
they'll probably still be stars
uh in existence and you can imagine
planets around those stars and
and intelligent life evolving on those
planets and astronomers would look out
from our galaxy at that time it'll be a
very different looking galaxy because
the andromeda galaxy will have collided
with it and
all sorts of things will happen but
they'd look out and the interesting
thing is
all other galaxies would have
disappeared behind the horizon by then
so
observers 10 trillion years from now
will think they live in the universe we
thought we lived in 1925
a universe with one galaxy and there'll
be no evidence that the universe is
expanding no direct evidence
because the galaxies that are now
markers that we can measure their motion
away from us they'll have disappeared
and even it turns out the causing
microwave background will have become
invisible by that time which is
another bit of evidence for the big bang
and while some really smart scientists
may come up with some pictures to say
well really i can
understand what we're seeing if we
assume our universe began in a big bang
observationally basically all the
current observational markers of an
expanding universe will have disappeared
and
poetically in the far future they'll
think we lived in the mistaken universe
we thought we lived in
in 1925 because again it's kind of
interesting
conventional wisdom in 1925
scientifically was
that the universe was static and eternal
and you may know that it was a it was
actually a jesuit priest who was uh who
was also a physicist
who first really suggested the big bang
and and um and when
and when it was later shown to be true
for a while the catholic church got
quite excited because they
argued that here was observational
evidence that there was a beginning to
the universe as they'd been arguing
it it doesn't provide would argue it
doesn't provide any such evidence for
the
universe they discussed but it was an
interesting fact that science
the the the model was that the universe
was more or less static and eternal
on large scales and it was completely
wrong and you might say
and this is where people often you know
write to me they say well how do we know
our current model isn't completely wrong
you know if not that we had a big bang
and the answer is
then there was no data basically and
you know whatever one of the biggest
misconceptions about science and
scientific revolutions in particular
revolutions in physics
is the misconception that scientific
revolutions do away with everything that
went before them and mm-hmm
just like they're called revolutions in
fact i would argue that even political
revolutions never do away with
everything that went before them but in
this case
they certainly don't what survived the
test of experiment before that
revolution
remains completely true newton's laws of
gravity and motion
may have been subsumed in quantum
mechanics or relativity but if i hold a
ball up now it'll fall just as well as
described and i can describe it
cannonball i can even for the most part
calculate how astronauts are going to go
to orbit without needing
anything yeah the developmental
psychologist piaget studied kuhn's
scientific revolutions and
his objection essentially was that when
a child undergoes a cognitive
restructuring the new structure
incorporates
all of the knowledge of the old one plus
some new knowledge so it could be
revolutionary but it still subsumes it
exactly and that's exactly what happens
in science so it's not as so we have a
lot of data
with which we can test ideas and i'm
certain that that
that there's much more we don't know
about the universe than we do
what people don't realize is or don't
give credit to is that there's a lot we
do understand
and any new picture a new understanding
can will not be able to disagree with
the observational evidence that the
universe is expanding that
there's a hot causing whiteway
background all the things we now have
discovered
that we didn't know about in 1925 and so
whatever our picture is of the beginning
of time or the end of time
in a hundred years may be very different
but
we know the it's not we're not going to
ever say the age of the universe is no
longer 13.7 billion years old
we you know we we that's that's going to
remain true
what happened at the beginning could be
completely revolutionarily different and
what happened
if you want to think about before the
beginning if there even makes sense to
describe it before
and it may not make sense because time
itself could have
originated let me ask you about that for
a second sure okay sure
well i thought a lot about time a long
time ago
and it struck me that
time is is we mark time by change and so
then i thought well
why why not dispense with time as a
concept if we market by change
time is average change
if nothing changes there's no time so if
there's nothing happening there's no
time there's no before that time it's
there's an event and then if there's no
event till the next event
there's no duration between those two
things if there's only
that event in the next event so i mean
is there any reason to assume that
there's anything about time that is
independent of change
well you know that's obviously it's a
very deep question
and a lot of people spend a lot of time
and time i think far too much time
talking about time
in physics time and space are not
different
they're both if you wish parameters that
simply describe
when events happen and where they happen
and um and that's it and
it turns out that that's the playing
field on which
the laws of nature play out the playing
field happens to be in space-time and
time is
no different than space in principle
except in fact in practice time seems
very different than space
we can go backwards in space but it's
not clear we can go backwards in time
and that's caused
a lot of people a lot of philosophers
and then physicists a lot of
problems a lot of mental gymnastics but
even um but
you could argue that time is a parameter
and i could replace that parameter by
some other parameter
that is equivalent to time and and
and you could say that that parameter
was change like the parameter you talk
about
and then if there's no t change
then you'd say okay well that's
you could say that that parameter isn't
it you know it it
isn't changing and you mean there's
changes happening all the time at the
at the microscopic level right i mean
there's an indefinite number of changes
and so
statistically you can extract out an
average from that and you can
and you can experience that as duration
and you can define that as time but
if there isn't anything there except one
event and then the next event
well that's that's it that there's no
time there there's an event and then
there's the next event
well that's well that's that's where i
disagree with you i guess that's right
because if nothing is happening
literally if nothing's happening
then time is an irrelevant concept but
so
so to some extent in space and to some
extent it's physics
because really what we're interested in
is is describing
the process of events in particular the
prediction of events
and um and that process for going by
from event to event is parametrized by a
useful
quantity called time but if if nothing's
happening you're right it's completely
arbitrary but then
we won't it wouldn't be worth having we
wouldn't be having this conversation
because nothing would be happening
so in a universe in which nothing was
happening there would be no time but
there'd be no reason
to talk about it either all right so
back to the beginning
now my understanding i don't understand
why there is something once something is
created because
as far as i could tell and i i don't
think i was disabused of this notion
with
with the i finished reading the greatest
story ever told so far this week
um why weren't there
equal amounts of matter and antimatter
produced at the beginning so they just
disappeared everything just disappeared
that's a good question
and we assume is that does that have
does that have anything to do with
uncertainty
with the fact that that there was there
isn't
i'm wondering if there wasn't equal
numbers
produced well
look the point is that we don't have an
answer to that question and by the way i
think that's really important as a
scientist
and too few people you know journalists
always want answers and people are
always disappointed when they say we
don't know
but i think it's probably one of the
most important things that we and
parents and teachers should get more
used to saying
because it means there's more to
discover and that's wonderful
so the answer is we really don't it's
one of the biggest it's questions that's
really provoked
much of the field of research that i've
been involved in since i was a
student i remember stephen weinberg
wrote about it when i was a
graduate student and got me interested
in the whole subject
we now know that we live in a universe
that's made of matter
and we try and measure antimatter and
there's minuscule amounts of it and we
think most of it's caused by high-energy
collisions between particles and causing
graves
as far as we can see and they're real
tests we can do for a while people
thought maybe we'd lived in a universe
that had equal amounts of matter and
antimatter
and they were separated you know there
were matter regions and antimatter
regions
but turns out there are tests you can do
to test that and all of those tests
demonstrate
as far as we can tell that there know
that the universe is made of matter not
antimatter
which again is arbitrary because of
course if we lived in the universe made
of antimatter
we'd call it matter and you know and
there'd be anti-lovers living in
anti-sitting anti-cars making anti-love
and all the rest
it wouldn't be different for the most
part um but
the paradox here is at early times
the universe is very very hot and when
it's so hot
you one of the central parts of
relativity is that energy can turn into
matter and matter can turn into energy
so particles of light with enough energy
can collide together and produce
particles of matter
okay but when they do that if they have
enough energy but since
antimatter and matter have exactly the
same mass
particles that collide will produce
equal amounts of matter and antimatter
if two photons at very high energy co
and they don't collide very easily but
if they do um
they'll produce particles and
antiparticles equal in equal numbers
partly because of the conservation of
charge right the photon doesn't have any
charge
and therefore whatever comes out of the
collision has to have no charge so if it
produces an electron
it'll have to have a positron the
equilibrium so
the all those interactions of elementary
particle interactions don't really
distinguish between
matter and antimatter and therefore at
very early times
if you were a creator if you were
creating a universe
and it was very hot and dense it would
the most reasonable thing
would be for it to have equal parts of
matter and antimatter okay
but somehow so that's the that's the
reasonable assumption for the beginning
of time that the universe had equal
amounts of matter and antimatter and a
very hot dense plasma
how do we get to a universe that just
has matter
well that is the interesting question
and it turns out by the way and i know
you're interested in
what you would call soviet uh things
you're like the art and everything else
and you probably and alexander
solzhenitsyn
um no i collect it i don't know if i
like it yeah okay you collected it
but i do collect it but andre andre
socceroff was a was a very famous
physicist who's actually probably the
father of their hydrogen bomb
but he was also as you know won the
nobel peace prize because he became a
dissident
interestingly enough one of his major c
well in retrospect one of his major
contributions to science
was he he actually asked in i think was
1967 well before
any of the physics actually allowed any
of the he came up with three criteria by
which
a universe that started out with equal
amounts of matter and antimatter
could could evolve into a universe which
just had matter
they're called the sakurao conditions
and there are three of them one is
that you have to depart from thermal
equilibrium because if you're in thermal
equilibrium everything remains the same
so nothing's going to happen right okay
thermal equilibrium like the air in this
room
okay so there's a place where
uncertainty seems to be relevant because
if the principle of uncertainty holds
you wouldn't have thermal equilibrium
you'd have
unavoidable variation well no but you
have thermal well you
no you do have local therm in thermal
equilibrium in this room there's local
variations
the thing about thermal equilibrium is
um and you're right
in fact what you just said there's right
normally we talk about thermal
equilibrium being a global thing
but we can also talk about microscopic
equilibrium and and that
and that and there are variations but
what happens is that
that in thermal equilibrium one particle
turns another particle you know
collision but an equal number of
collisions happen in the opposite
direction
so so there's lots of things happening
but but they're all happening in equal
opposite ways so that
no global properties are changing okay
okay and certainly
and certainly the amount of matter in
the universe is a global property okay
so thermal equilibrium but you okay the
second
is that you have to have some
physical process that tells the
difference between
particles of uh of
matter and antimatter okay because if
the physical processes don't tell the
difference
then nothing's going to start a
situation that has equal numbers and
change it to a situation that has
unequal numbers okay this
th this property is called a it happens
to be a
the the laws of physics that tell you
matter and antimatter
uh uh the laws of physics are the same
for matter and antimatter
are related to two symmetries of nature
something called charge conjugation and
variance which tells you that
that that that positive and negative
there's no difference between positive
and negative it's just an arbitrary
thing and it turns out there's no
difference between left and right okay
if those if if the laws of physics at a
microscopic level obey both of those
properties then the laws of physics will
not distinguish between matter and
antimatter
only if though that's violated that's
called cp
charge and parity only if cp is violated
can you by some microscopic physical law
can you evolve from a system with an
equal number of particles and
anti-particles to one that hasn't
and the third is something called
uh well we call it baryon number
non-conservation but basically
matter is made of protons okay
and you know electrons are a little
obviously protons and electrons wake up
atoms but electrons
are very little mass most of the mass in
your body is protons and neutrons
they're called baryons okay and clearly
if you want to end up with a universe
full of protons and neutrons
and more protons and neutrons if you
wish than
than antiprotons and anti-neutrons
then there has to be some process that
makes protons
when there weren't protons to begin with
so those are three so that's
thermal equilibrium cp and violate so
violation of thermal equilibrium
violation of cp invariants and some
process
that violates what are called barrier
number that that
okay and he wrote those down and what's
amazing is at the time you wrote them
down
the laws of physics obeyed thermal
equilibrium in the
universe obeyed cp and obeyed baron
number so there's no evidence that you
could ever do that
and what's been remarkable is that over
the last
50 years or so is as we've studied the
microscopic laws of physics we've
discovered
both that cp is violated
by microscopic laws and
we've we've discovered processes that
could have happened in the early
universe
that would violate that thermal
equilibrium that nice general
what you call adiabatic expansion of the
universe there could have been abrupt
processes
during which the universe departed from
thermal equilibrium by
natural processes that we could describe
in fact we know there were some of them
we know
if you read my book we know for example
now that
the two forces of nature
electromagnetism and the weak
interaction
that now appear very different
early on in the history of the universe
actually represented two different sides
of the same coin they were really
part of a single more unified force okay
and the point where the universe cooled
down enough so that suddenly
electromagnetism began
to behave differently than the weak
interaction
as the universe cooled down and things
suddenly began to behave differently
that's what we call a phase transition
and
phase transitions are places where you
can depart from thermal equilibrium
right if i i think i don't know if i use
the example in the book but it
and i and i grew up in canada so the
example is beer
but if i if you if you have a party and
a beer party and you forget to put
beer in the refrigerator you put it in
the freezer and
and and then you forget that you put it
in the freezer and the next day you take
it out of the freezer and it's frozen
solid
uh i mean it's not frozen solid it's
still it's still liquid but you
you click the you take off the top and
suddenly it freezes instantaneously
and the bottle breaks that's a phase
transition because when the
when the beer was being held under high
pressure it wasn't in
at a low temperature it wasn't really in
thermal equilibrium when you opened it
up
then it could suddenly go into thermal
equilibrium and the preferred state to
be in the thermal equilibrium was ice
and suddenly boom and break it so
thermal equilib so so phase transitions
are points where you can violate
you can depart from thermal equilibrium
momentarily
before the transition completes
there's a theoretical uh explanation for
how the anti-matter matter
uh well there the point is there's no
one theoretical explanation but we now
know
all the parts the sacchari okay okay
exist
but we don't have any good model that
puts them all together as we thought we
did in the 1980s when i was
a when i was at harvard we thought we we
we thought there were
even before that when i was doing my phd
at mit we thought there was a model
called grand unification
it all looked like it was falling
together and we thought we had the
answer to everything and it turned out
the experiments have told us that those
pictures are not quite right
there's a host of possible ways of
starting out with the universe that
that is that has made equal amounts of
matter and antimatter and ending up with
the universe that
has unequal amounts but we don't know if
any of the proposals that we've now made
are correct and if
history is any guide my feeling always
is most like the most likely answer is
one we don't yet have
i mean i've written papers lots of
models that can make that happen
but nature probably isn't smart enough
to use any of the models that i've
written down
and i suspect it but so there are lots
of ways but but what's neat is that
experiments have shown and that's what's
important it's not just theoretical
you know mumblings of physicists who
like to have nothing better to do
experiments have shown all the
components of the sakharov
um uh requirements for generating matter
a universe that was had an asymmetry are
possible in nature
and and and are suggested i i i should
be a little more careful
we know phase transitions happened in
the early universe we know cp is
violated
baryon number we don't know to be
violated but
all of our models that extend what's
called the standard model of particle
physics
naturally produce at very early times
models where barian number is violated
so so it's not implausible
it's it's certainly not implausible and
so all those things exist
and and and our current picture it's
really quite having said all of that
that's complicated
the current picture that
is a little simple and it's really
remarkable it says
that what happened is there were equal
amounts of matter and antimatter and
a physical process happened sometime
between
the big bang and the time when the
universe was about
a millionth of a second old that caused
a very slight excess one part in a
billion
more particles of matter than antimatter
and that's all you need
you might say why is that the case
because we now live in a universe
that's just matter well if i have one ex
let's say there's a billion and one
particles of matter
and a billion particles of antimatter
what will happen as the universe evolves
the particles of matter will annihilate
with the particles of antimatter
producing radiation but there'll be one
leftover particle that couldn't find the
particle antimatter annihilate
so what you'd expect is roughly a
billion particles of radiation in the
universe
for every particle of matter and when we
look out that's exactly what we see
the causing microwave background
contains roughly a billion
one to a billion to ten billion photons
throughout going throughout all of space
for every proton in the universe
so in fact while we think we really live
in a universe if of matter
what we really live is a universe that's
mostly radiation
polluted by a little teeny teeny bit of
matter one part in a billion but that
teeny bit of matter is enough to make
all of the gas stars and galaxies in you
and i
so like one of the things that i'd like
to think of in physics is it makes us
more and more insignificant as human
beings
and it cosmic sense we realize we used
to think we're the center of the
universe where the son of
the sun you know the sun went around us
it's been a series of these kind of
copernican revolutions where the earth
isn't the center of the
of our solar system but the sun isn't
the center of our galaxy
but our galaxy isn't the center of a
cluster of galaxies and our cluster of
galaxies isn't the center of the
universe
and now we find that most of the
particles in the universe aren't even
made of the same stuff as we are
so it pushes us more and more to feeling
marginal and
i find that and a lot of people say well
that should make us feel
sad but to me it makes me feel more
precious
rather than less precious it's like
obviously we're getting into the realm
of psychology
but my psychological response is hey
the fact that the universe is accidental
as far as i can see and was created
without any supernatural shenanigans the
fact that
we're cosmically irrelevant the fact
that the universe is going to go on
without us
all that doesn't make me feel sad it
makes me feel i should enjoy my brief
moment of the sun i should enjoy my
brief
you know four score and ten or hopefully
more and and years and
and and it and it makes this accident of
life on on earth
remarkable that we that evolution has
endowed us with a consciousness so you
and i can have these discussions
so i don't find a pointlessness of the
universe to be depressing i find it
rather
the opposite and i often and this may be
an area we disagree in i don't know but
but one of the bits of semantics that
i've tried to fight
is this notion of loss of faith like
losing your faith is a loss
but to me losing my faith in
in those those fairy tales at least or
the or those
incorrect explanations is not a loss
it's a game
it's a it's and using that terminology
makes it seem like people always write
to me
i now recognize you know that i don't
believe the the bible stories but what
am i to do i mean
how can i deal with this loss and and i
think they're conditioned to feel like
they
they have a loss i i don't think so i
think you can
at least you can psychologically
create a picture where you don't feel
that's a loss you feel in fact you've
gained something
and and actually it's the way i feel
about many things in life when i'm
being well adjusted which is a small
percentage of the time to be clear um
when i have a loss i often reflect on it
afterwards and realize
in fact how i've gained that what seemed
to be a traumatic experience
or in the end produce something which is
much more valuable and
of course it's a rationalization
probably but it allows me to deal with
those things anyway
anyway that's my little bit of
psychology my little bit of pop
psychology for our
discussion i'm tempted to take it in the
direction but i think i'm going to
continue to torture you about the
structure of the universe
i i would i could do that because one of
the things that i hope your
listeners will know is that you and i
are going to have a podcast on my
podcast i can't wait to have you
on my past maybe we'll be in together in
the same room and then i will do
i will torture you okay okay that sounds
like
i'm i'm looking forward to that a lot
okay so so
so matter pops into being essentially
after things cool down to some degree
and the
there there are different there aren't
exactly different
laws governing the universe before that
but
the what would you say the the
allowances that the current laws make
have a
a remarkably powerful effect before that
yeah yeah absolutely
the the form that the laws i mean the
laws of physics do evolve
at energy scales and and which laws are
important and different energy scales
are are different so certain laws of
physics even if even if they
don't change at all certain certain
things are more important early on
and then other laws become important
more important later on like now
obviously electromagnetism on small
scales is incredibly important it
governs all the biology all the
chemistry all of the things that we see
in
around in the world around us um at
early times it was nuclear physics and
particle physics that the laws of the
strong and weak interaction that were
determining what was going on
but you're right eventually and it took
a while
it took a long time before the universe
became dominated by matter
even when the universe was one second
old and a temperature of about 10
billion degrees
there weren't even elements all of the
uh that's the other thing that's
remarkable until the universe was
even protons didn't exist until the
universe was about a
somewhere about a millionth of a
millionth of a second old
but elements didn't exist all of the
light elements
hydrogen helium and lithium were if you
wish
created by nuclear reactions in the
first
five minutes of the universe which is
why stephen weinberg's book called the
first three minutes talks about that
so and those were the only elements
created at the beginning of time
hydrogen and they're created from the
lightest upward
and that's the that's basically the way
that things go across the entire yeah
you start with protons and and in fact
and it's kind of it protons and neutrons
but neutrons are actually unstable so
they decay into protons
it's very fortunate it turns out if you
want to believe in coincidence this is
really quite amazing
it's very fortunate that it works out
the neutrons live about 10 minutes
and if i had a neutron here and held in
my hand in 10 minutes on average it
would decay
well you and i have more neutrons in our
body than protons how can that be the
case we've been talking for a lot more
than 10 minutes i'm sure your listeners
are quite aware of that
but the reason is if you put a neutron
in a nucleus
it can become stable okay and it's
really quite fortunate that all the
neutrons that are more or less
many of the neutrons that now exist in
the universe got trapped in this form of
helium
and lithium because protons hydrogen
just has a proton and electron
okay there's a heavy hydrogen which is
deuterium which is a proton and a
neutron electron and
some of that was created in the universe
too but helium has two protons and two
neutrons
and so by those neutrons being by helium
forming by a series of remarkable
nuclear reactions
the universe if you wish stored the
neutrons that otherwise would have
decayed away into protons and there'd be
no neutrons left in these
and so they've been stored ever since
that time for the most part yeah they
have been exactly
and so those the neutron and and of
course other neutrons have been created
in the in the
fiery cores of stars so what happens is
and and i talked about it
in in the universe or nothing in in a
lecture i gave you that sort of was the
formation of that book
and i'm not the first person to say that
i know carl sagan talked in different
ways
but it is really true what's important
for the psychology that you study
is carbon nitrogen oxygen phosphorus
iron all of those things none of those
elements
were created in the big bang all of
those elements were created
much later literally billions of years
later or hundreds of millions of
millions years later in the fiery course
of stars where nuclear reactions happen
and that means something that is really
truly the most poetic thing i do know
about nature
that every atom in your body in the
first first approximation all the carbon
all the oxygen
was create was in created inside of a
star and that means you know we're
getting
inside of the star and not just forage
inside the star but in order to get into
your body that star had to explode
so all the atoms in your body and in
fact probably they've been in many stars
because you've probably
many generations they've experienced the
most catastrophic
explosion in in nature a supernova
every atom in your body has experienced
that at least once if not many times
it's
you are a stardust it's i mean you know
it's it it sounds
you know it's so remarkable that it
sounds cliched yeah yeah exactly
but it's when i really like the
discussion of love yeah exactly is the
case
but you know what makes it less
remarkable for me as an analogy i gave
is that the atoms in your left hand
could have come from a different star
than the atoms in your right hand i just
find that
amazing anyway it doesn't matter
whatever turns your turns you on
so what do you think okay so now we're
at the point in the story where
atoms are beginning to form and they're
starting with their simple
forms and that's it within the first
three minutes yeah for five minutes and
the
first five minutes and so and then so
it's it's
it's hydrogen first and then it's helium
and then it's
let me even correct you again because
well correct me
the nuclei of atoms form but in fact
there were no atoms
until the universe was 300 000 years old
because
it was so hot that when atoms exist when
protons and neutrons capture electrons
right
then you get a whole atom but in the
early history of the universe it was so
hot that when electron got captured it
got knocked out again
so there were only these nuclei which
were charged
of protons and electrons and everything
you know and it was
a plasma of these things only when the
universe cooled down
to about um about a thousand degrees or
so
maybe ten thousand degrees somewhere in
that region was the universe cool enough
so that protons could capture electrons
and neutral hydrogen would form and
those were the first atoms
literally atom neutral atoms that
existed in the universe and that's when
if you wish the causing microwave
background
separated from matter because then once
matter became neutral instead of being a
bunch of charged objects
then light and matters kind of decoupled
and that was a momentous period and that
was the first moment that neutral atoms
began
when universal so that's about 300 000
years yeah
and then not much happened i mean and
then you know from 300 000 years
what happened is the universe cooled and
cooled and cooled
and really um it was
it was um and the dark ages if you wish
because
you know there were no stars it was just
matter and radiation but
the original and it's fairly uniformly
distributed and it's understanding and
cooling
unbelievably uniformly distributed this
was one of the big surprises
einstein in order to make a model of the
universe
your models are simple so you you know
einstein and others would make models in
which universe was uniform
because only then could you do the
calculations but then when we look out
we discovered empirically this
remarkable fact which for a long time
was quite surprising and now we have
this idea of inflation that in principle
explains it but it is that the universe
is uniform across
regions that could never have been in
causal contact before today
that's really important the region way
over there could not have communicated
that region over there before today
but they have the same temperature to
one part and a hundred thousand
it's remarkable the universe is you
unbelievably and that's the cosmic
background microwave radiation yeah
you're talking about it's
the same in every direction in every
direction right and since matter was
couple the radiation the more or less
distribution of matter is is
is uniform around the universe but now
it's not because you and i are in
you know in different places and you
know that you shouldn't matter but it
sounds like it's another one of those
situations where small discontinuities
at the beginning were enough to produce
very large
differences across time exactly because
gravity is attractive
that's the key point so if you have
small lumps anywhere
a little small excess here will begin to
grow
and then that snowballs so to speak and
and that's exactly the case there were
small and this is another amazing fact
which is is not appreciated enough
the small fluctuations the microwave
background we think we're due to quantum
mechanics yeah
that's where i was thinking about the
quantum uncertainty sorry it's not the
earlier
we are literally quantum lumps if you
wish in order
to in order to get those because there's
quantum discontinuity
discontinuity uncertainty on microscopic
scales
that causes clumping well eventually it
allows clumping to occur
yeah the point is that we don't see
quantum fluctuations on our scales
but remember the entire observable
universe was once
inside a region that's the size of an
atom and those scales quantum
fluctuations are very important
and what's amazing is those quantum
fluctuations got frozen in
into the into the microwave background
characteristics in ways that we can
predict
and describe and those quantum
fluctuations later formed
all the stars and galaxies and
everything else because they were lumps
so we really are macroscopic
manifestations of quantum mechanics if
you want to think of it okay so let me
ask you a question about that quantum
fluctuation
so there is uncertainty of location and
posit location and speed yes i've got
that right
yeah there's uncertainty in the
combination okay but that uncertainty is
real enough so that in that
relatively uniform background there were
actual let's say fluctuations
there were discontinuities of position
that were sufficient to cause
they're not only were inevitable they're
required
and right but that's really that's
that's a real that's an
actual phenomenon oh it's even more it's
more not only more real and more
but it's also more wild than you just
said that what you just said may not
surprise people but
what's even weirder is when you go to
the smaller scales
for very there's another uncertainty
principle in quantum mechanics since
there's a position and momentum
uncertainty but there's a energy and
time uncertainty
and the certainty is if you can measure
a system for only a short time
then your ability to measure its energy
is very uncertain
so if you can measure it for a longer
time your uncertainty energy goes away
if you measure it for a small time your
uncertainty in energy gets very large
okay and that means for very short times
empty space can burp out particles
and pi anti-particles you say well that
violates the conservation of energy
because there's nothing there
to begin with and you know when i put
pump out a
burp out of electron or posture on
suddenly there are particles
is that how black holes evaporate that
is a mechanism by which black holes can
be thought of as evaporating if you want
to get there
right because they they particles pop up
you can continuously some of them fall
into the black hole
that's way one way of describing hawking
radiation it's a it's a not a bad
analogy it's not a bad it's got problems
but it's not a bad analogy
but in real i'm glad i'm not completely
off the wall here no no no no no you're
you're dabbling around no you're you're
so far you haven't
accept your questions about time you're
right on you're right on track
anyway um so this says
that particles can suddenly
spontaneously burp out of nothing
because
as long as they disappear again in a
time so short that we can't measure
their existence
they don't violate anything they don't
only violate energy conservation if we
could measure them
now that sounds crazy and it sounds like
it sounds like something sounds
something like potential well it's yeah
or
to be well that's right they have
potential to do things but
to be less generous they sound like
talking about how many angels can dance
on the head of a pen right
because if you can't see them if you
can't see them then what the hell does
it matter
the point is we can't see them but they
have indirect effects
that's what's remarkable so we know that
process is happening not just because
physicists like me say it's happening
but because if you take say a hydrogen
atom
you got a proton an electron laws of
quantum mechanics
that dirac developed allow you to
calculate the energy levels that that
electron can have around a proton
and that determines the colors of light
that's emitted by hydrogen right okay
we can compare those predictions with
observations and
and that's one of the basis of knowing
that quantum mechanics works
this discrete set of light that's
emitted by hydrogen
well it works but it doesn't really work
because it turns out
at a gross level it works but when you
try and measure things at the level
of one part in a thousand or so
it doesn't work it turns out the energy
levels aren't exactly what you'd think
they were
why is that that is because the proton
the hydrogen atom isn't just a proton
electron
it's a proton electron but in the atom
virtual particles are popping in and out
of existence
and say an electron positron pair pops
in into existence
in the atom in the atom within the
confines of the electron
yeah yeah exactly in that region well
it's happening everywhere in space but
it's also happening in atom
but in that region during the time
before that electron positron pair
disappears
the electron in that pair will want to
hang around close to the proton
because negative charges are attractive
positive charges whereas the positron
will be
kind of repelled and that'll change the
charge distribution
inside the atom in a way that we can
calculate
in a way that make every atom somewhat
unique
well it no yes and no every atom is
experiencing the same thing
because what's happening is the
particles i mean
what's happening again statistically is
that is that
those all those virtual particles and
anti-particles are changing
the spectrum of hydrogen of all hydrogen
atoms
by the same amount because they're
happening so fast they're changing
that spectrum in a way that we can
calculate
and it is one of the triumphs of
theoretical physics
that using a theory called quantum
electronamics developed by
feynman and others and building on what
directed
we can calculate to 14 decimal places
14 decimal places from first principles
what the spectrum of of hydrogen should
be
and how those virtual particles could
change that spectrum and when we compare
with observation
it it's bang on there's no other place
in science that we can make a
theoretical prediction from first
principles
and compare it to 14 decimal places with
observation and get the right answer so
that tells us
that those virtual particles that we
can't see are really there
okay and that means empty space is much
more complicated
than we had assumed before which is
part of what led you to the hypothesis
that empty space was it was it was okay
so that's all part of the background for
that
so empty space is a seething pool of of
virtual particles popping in and out of
existence constantly
and that does sound a lot like potential
like yeah and that means not only has a
potential but it can have
but those but that effect can cause
empty space to have energy
in fact generically you would expect
so you might say what's so surprising so
it's not surprising that empty space has
energy what's surprising in a sense
is that empty space has so little energy
you might why
why does it have energy if this if the
particles
sum to zero over a short time well
that's a really good
that's a really good point and the the
um
the answer is a little more complicated
and it is that
um let me give you an example from
quantum mechanics
so if i have a what the famous quantum
mechanical example of a potential
well i have a little u-shaped well right
and and if i have a a ball
on that well you know it'll roll down
the ball but frick with the well but
friction will eventually cause it to
rest at the bottom
at the lowest energy state right it'll
lose energy by friction along
the most energy state it turns out in
quantum mechanics because
energy states are quantized in such a
potential well
the lowest energy state is not at the
bottom of the potential well
it's a little bit above the bottom
and so the ground state the lowest
energy state that an electron can have
trapped in a well
is not at the bottom of the well it's
actually it's actually has a little bit
more energy than the bottom because the
energy states are quantized
classically the energy that means it
can't get to zero it can't get to zero
that's a generic property of an electron
in a potential well
it's an amazing fact so that's called
the ground state energy
in quantum mechanics and is there a why
to that
i mean you said it's because it's
quantized and well i presume that's an
explanation but it's not an explanation
i understand okay
okay again let me give you a heuristic
explanation that you might get better
okay you might not like it as much but
it's one it's one that i use in my own
mind so maybe it'll help
remember we tell us in in quantum
mechanics particles are also waves
right so the electron has a wavelength
okay i don't know if you play music do
you play music at all
badly me too very badly but i like to
play okay
so when i when i when i um when i hit a
piano key
i hear a note why because that string
has a certain length
and the only and they're vibrations that
can be on that string
but the only vibrations that persist are
ones that have a very specific
relationship with their wavelength to
the length of that string
that's called resonance right so and
that's why because
they go because the wave goes along the
string it comes back then it bounces
back and comes along
and reinforces but only when the
wavelength in that case is exactly equal
to the length of the string
will you have resonance will the string
be able to persist
okay now electron has a wavelength and
the way to think about
a stationary state of an electron is
it's like it's like
a resonant note in a musical instrument
so i have a potential well
and the electron can only exist at those
distances
where it where its wavelength is an
exact relationship to the
to the width of the potential well so is
it reasonable to say that
that i mean electron can't exist and
have zero energy
that's not possible um let me let me
think if that's a
good a good if it were
the only way it could is if its
wavelength were infinitely big
because it turns out the wavelength of
an electron is related to its total
energy
inversely related so if you want to
think about this
an electron that's at rest if you want
to think about it would have a
wavelength that
what's called the broiling wavelength
which is infinitely big in size
so if the universe so only in an
infinitely big universe could an
electron really
have a ground state energy that's
exactly zero
all right now i'm going to ask one more
question about this then i'm going to
shut up about this
um is that also uh uncertainty issue is
because
if it's at zero you can specify it
exactly so then it has to have
an infinitely large wavelength that's
the reason that's basically the answer
certainly more or less yeah
it's it's it's position if you do if you
more or less
if it's at rest its momentum is exactly
zero right and you can exactly
specify i don't know where its position
is and therefore it can its position is
equally likely anywhere in the universe
so only yeah so okay okay okay i know
it's crazy it's crazy yeah well these
are more like descript they're like
they're like concurrent incomprehensible
descriptions rather than explanations
well yeah well you accept the theory
that's what
you can predict obviously and it works
but i mean but but there's something
you've
hit on which is really important a lot
of people get hung up on the
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
people write books about it in many
worlds and they you know lately there's
somebody who wrote a book and tried to
sell books
but the point is that it's nice to talk
about all that but it's really
irrelevant because that's
actually a brilliant i first realized it
due to a colleague of mine at harvard
who was really the smartest person there
in the physics department he's now dead
sydney coleman he said the proper thing
to talk about is not the interpretation
of quantum mechanics
it's the interpretation of classical
mechanics because the real world is
quantum mechanical
and any classical picture we impose on
is going to be crazy
and and but you don't have to think of
it as real they're all just different
approximations
to a reality an underlying reality which
can't be described by a cl any classical
picture
so that's why all these classical
pictures seem crazy because that none of
them is complete
well you know if you look at well if you
look at this psychologically i'm going
to refer to piaget again i mean
piaget pointed out that we derive our
concepts from our practical
our practical manipulations of things so
for example you know you might ask why
well why is this one thing you know i
could say well it's five
things yeah well the question is well
what's a thing yeah well
look it moves as a unit therefore it's a
thing
so that's one well it could be five if i
broke it apart now it's two
but it's it's it the the concept itself
is predicated on
our interactions at this scale and so
we're going to derive our sense of
reality from our practical interactions
at this scale
and your claim the claim of the quantum
mechanics in general is that that
doesn't apply at the micro scale
so our intuitions are gone because our
intuitions are predicated on our
embodiment at this level of analysis
absolutely in fact the purpose of the
greatest story we're told so far that
particular book is to say
something remarkable the world of our
experience
is an illusion i i know i hate to say it
because it breeds all sorts of
mumbo-jumbo and people
start doing but it at a fundamental
scale at the small scales
everything that this that defines our
universe including
matter and and um
and mass really the things that
make the universe the universe we
experience are really
accidents of our circumstances rather
than
fundamental properties of the universe
so our universe well that's something
that's something i would
like and we can do this again when we
talk again because i
i'm i'm i'm always curious about that
leap into purposelessness and
one of the things i would like to ask
you just briefly on that subject
um is as the universe cools we do see a
gradual increase in at least
one sort of important complexity
right and that's the building of the
let's say the building of the periodic
table
and so atoms become more and more
complex and sophisticated as the
universe cools
that seems like a kind of directionality
that's built into the structure itself
and it isn't i mean do you think that's
disc con
is that necessarily discontinuous with
the
radical increase in complexity that you
start to see 3.5 billion years ago when
life emerges
or is that the same process of
complexification
well you know okay it's a good question
and the answer is
it's all momentary it's
it's a momentary accident it is true
that the stars
as they as star individual stars evolve
they build up
heavier and heavy elements okay they do
it at the expense of their surroundings
by
increasing the disorder in their
surroundings right they're emitting
right right okay so right so there's
localized
okay there's localized increase in
complexity like us yeah
but it's all momentary if you follow it
long enough
the heavy elements are going to
disappear matter is going to disappear
and the long term the universe will look
will just be pure radiation again so we
are
so this build up of complexity which are
absolutely true is not a
is not a direction of the universe it's
a momentary but
fortunate imbalance that will exist for
a while until the universe catches up
with it yeah well that's
now that's a real problem in discussing
concepts isn't it because
you can take a time scale and change the
time scale and all of a sudden the
phenomena changes completely
and that's what people do to themselves
often when they think about the
meaninglessness
of their life it's like well wait a
second i could make the case i've made
this with my clients
approximately is uh if you're thinking
on a time
scale that makes your life irrelevant
that's the wrong
time scale for the problem that's the
indic the hopelessness is an indication
that you're using the wrong frame
absolutely and and you'd say well what's
the proof of that and i would say well
the hopelessness is the proof of that
now you might not regard that as proof
but it's a point that's at least worth
considering
you know because you could say well what
good is a beethoven symphony
across a span of a trillion years it's
like well none but yeah
why what good is posing that question
exactly well i i couldn't agree with you
more the fact that
that we have there's no obvious purpose
the universe the fact that we
and everything we've created will long
be gone that that can depress you but
the
the opposite side of the coin it seems
to me if i were a
clinician that i would try to argue to
my clients is that it makes
every moment of that accident of your
own existence
special and every instant is more
special because it's finite
because because it's it it's so unique
and therefore you're right there may be
no cosmic purpose to your existence
but you create your own purpose i know
you write about meaning or a whole book
about meaning but
but i would argue there's no objective
meaning to the universe we make our own
meaning
and to the extent we make our own
meaning our lives are more or less
valuable to us
and to others around us and so i would
say see i would i would quibble with
that
and maybe it's not just a quibble
because i don't think meaning is
something we create i think it's
something that manifests itself to us
now look i know i know it's not that
simple because we do make decisions but
it's very frequently the case and you
know this you know this is a scientist
for example you may have an in moment of
insight into some phenomena so that's
deeply meaningful but
it isn't so much that that is something
you create although you can seek it out
it's more like that something that
bursts on you
yeah yeah okay well i i it'll be
interesting question to see if we're
debating semantics here or not
yeah yeah right right right and um well
i mean
the reason i i guess i guess at a
fundamental scale and maybe we can
follow this up in our in in when we talk
for in my podcast but i i
tend not to think that there's any
objective meaning
to the universe there's existence well
it may be that objective and meaning
aren't well suited for one another
right because you could also make the
case that the objective viewpoint
precludes meaning as part of its
operation yeah and i think it
i mean you can make a strong case that
the scientific method is designed to
exclude subjective meaning
that's actually and that's actually one
of its remarkable strengths but it has a
cost
the cost is well what do you do with the
phenomena of meaning
well it doesn't exist scientifically
well
that is something we could talk about
for a long time because that'll pull us
into it
the question of whether what's
constituted
conceptualized as objective reality is a
sufficiently sophisticated conception of
reality
itself and it isn't obvious to me that
it is because it does have this tendency
to include
to exclude the subjective by its by its
method
okay that's good because i yeah i would
say it's for me it's perfectly fine
um the fact that exclusive reactive is
its strength not its weakness
in my opinion it is it is one of its
strengths there's no doubt about that
because
the subject because by excluding the
subjective you can discover
what's transpersonally universal but but
that also may mean that there are things
you exclude that are
real that that are necessary you know
you well to
to you know i used to read well there's
a i like oliver
so i used to read a lot and one of his
last books before he died was
on hallucinations and one of the things
that really at the beginning of his book
that really hit me
and it was relevant to something i was
working on at the time and i honestly
forget it but
is his point that to people who are
experiencing hallucinations they're real
and and yeah well that's the thing about
real real is realistic there is
objectively real let's make no mistake
about that and objectively real is
powerful but
it isn't obvious to me that objective
and real are synonymous well when
it comes so when it comes to our own our
own
psyche i couldn't agree with you more
which is why i tell people by the way
when i was a kid i wanted to be a what i
would have if my my neither my parents
went to university so i didn't know the
term neuroscience so i want to be a
brain surgeon
my mother wanted me to be a doctor a
nice jewish boy and and um
and uh i wanted to be and what
interested me most was the brain
and i thought well neurosurgery must be
the way to do it i didn't realize it
wasn't but
um but the reason i one of the reasons i
do physics
is it's so much damn easier it's just so
much easier than psychology or
neuroscience it's
because because of these complexities of
of
psyche and and so i do go back to this
reason as a slave of passion i mean
the fact that we that are that our our
whole
understanding of our own existence is
not really based on reason
i try as a scientist certainly not based
on our capacity to
to uh what would you say to
conceptualize objective reality that
isn't how people think christ
we've only thought like that for 500
years yeah that you know it's really
powerful but
yeah but it's not the way we naturally
and that's also something that's
really mysterious to me well you know
but it's that's what's so wonderful
about science to me is
there's a recognition that scientists
are people which is a secret that most
people don't realize
and um and therefore they're subjective
they're subject to all of the
the whims and and slings and arrows of
fortune and and
so the scientific method is developed to
realize that scientists are bound
to make mistakes and be human
and the scientific method is to catch
those mistakes i i
i argued recently in fact at oxford
union and they didn't get the point
because
they're all woke but um the students but
but there were you know there was a
debate that's terrible that's a terrible
thing
i know that's the case it's so terrible
you'll be surprised there was a debate
on
the question was we are all religious
and i asked to speak on the pro side
my colleagues my atheist colleagues who
people you know
uh were on the ante side and they were
shocked that i wanted to pick on the
prosecutor
and my argument was quite simple if we
weren't all religious we wouldn't need
science
if we didn't all want to believe right
that's that's exactly right man
that's exactly okay so we agree i mean
they didn't get the point and and i
would
well that was part of what i was trying
to point out to sam harris is that
and this is something i learned at least
in part from reading jung and his
claim was that alchemy
the the ideas of alchemy grew out of a
religious foundation and then science
emerged out of elk
it's like it's nested science is nested
inside an alchemical fantasy that's
nested inside a religious fantasy
well i wouldn't say nested i would say
it grew out of it like i
i i was born from my mother and father
who you know and i i like to think that
i grew
that a lot of what i who i am is that
but i grew up
here's why i think it has to be nested
still now and this is something we could
talk about a lot
the objects that draw a scientist's
attention
aren't determined by scientific
processes
you're you're the fantas you see what i
mean is that well
like you get interested in some things
and you pursue those now that's informed
by your scientific knowledge but
it's a it's so jung's point for example
was that
science was a materialist redemptive
myth that grew up as a counter position
to the spiritualist redemptive myth
right so you imagine there was an idea
which was that
we could redeem our inadequacy through
spiritual discipline
okay we tried that for a long time it
wasn't enough
people were still suffering from leprosy
okay so there's a fantasy emerges over
thousands of years
maybe we should investigate the
transformations of matter
there's redemptive information residing
in the transformations of matter
we could investigate that and that would
make life better
and so the motivational goal behind
science is
the expansion of human competence and
that's not a scientific
goal that's a motivational goal yeah i
agree with you but where i guess that we
disagree
and we could have this discussion is
that i think you're right and that's
what i said before scientists
are people so they're motivated by all
they're motivated by greed by fame by
jealousy
as well as by facts
on wonder i mean i would you know i want
to point out i mean we're all you know
that's why i'm assigned as i'm
demonstrating
on wonder and fascination but but i'm
also the questions i ask are totally
determined by the time in which i live
so but i don't want to be post-modern
because the point is
that what's great so that's all true
from a psychological perspective so you
may say that the motivations of science
are
are kind of a personal fantasy but
what's great
is the science overcomes that so that
you're right there are in fact
if you in my book in the in the book you
read the great server told so far i make
a big point of saying
scientists were all moving in this
direction and it was the wrong direction
wait but the science comes the subject
doesn't overcome the motivation
it doesn't overcome the motivation it
overcomes the con it overcomes the
contamination of the theory by the
motivational impulse but the motivation
changes because the phys
because the results force it upon you
scientists are forced
kicking and screaming to change their
minds
they don't want to but that motivation
of the kind of questions you ask
come be and that's the greatness of
science because it's empirical
because it's not based on just what i
want
but what nature tells me is the case and
so eventually
all the scientists who want this and are
and no doubt were driven in that
direction because they wanted that
find out that that one is wrong and they
have to go over here
and that's the beauty of science it's
that nature determines what's beautiful
ultimately you know you know i there was
a while when string theorists talked
about the elegant universe and all that
elegant and beauty don't matter nature
determines it not
scientists and eventually we get drawn
until we
eventually come to a picture where we
think it's beautiful but it was nature
you know something that was incredibly
ugly in the beginning that we thought
was ugly
ends up being beautiful because we force
our picture to understand that that's
the way it really is and then we
we develop an understanding of it but so
that's the beauty it's that
i guess i i don't think of it as a
fantasy in that sense maybe the
motivation is fanta
fantastical and even the process at some
level well there's a problem there's a
proposition right which which i think
maybe look let me let me give you
another example of this and you tell me
what you think
okay okay so um i'll try to formulate
this properly
um although i may not be able to do it
we have a hypothesis
that it's a fantasy i would say that the
increase of knowledge through technical
means
will be of benefit to us as individuals
and as a species
okay that is a that is a fantasy
now it may be accurate it's the fantasy
that we've staked ourselves on
but there's it's not provable and we're
actually ambivalent about it because
we generate apocalyptic nightmares all
the time and we know that our
technological prowess has a frankenstein
element
so it's not like we're 100 convinced
that this non-stop
onslaught of knowledge generation is
necessarily in our best interests
and you could also make a case an
evolutionary case that
most species are stunningly conservative
if something works man they do not
deviate from
whereas we're just transforming like mad
and so we do have this fantasy which is
we can escape
our static destiny by the acquisition of
knowledge by going out into the unknown
that's star trek right
you wrote books on the physics of star
trek to go boldly where no one has gone
beyond
before and that that will be of net
benefit to us
and that's the fantasy which with when
which this is nested
i don't think that does change you know
i mean i understand your point
within that there's transformations
constantly i think but i think it
wouldn't well
look i agree with you to the most part
and in fact regarding the
the apocalyptic things you must one of
the things you didn't mention is that i
was chairman of the board of sponsors of
the bolton atomic scientists for a dozen
years
that sets the doomsday clock so every
year i'd have to stare apocalypse right
in the in the face
but i think the the reason that fantasy
has persisted i would argue is that it
like many fantasies is that it has an
evolutionary success
and the reason i agree and the reason
that it persists is that we have found
that yeah when we developed antibiotics
we can live longer i mean so
there's a hope and you're right and and
it comes back to what i said before
reason is a slave of passion i recognize
that when i think i'm being you know i
mean driven by pure rationality i have
to recognize that there's
that there's passion can't be and that
well that's it this is
so okay and i think part of that again
this is something i tried to draw my
conversations with
with harris is well we are evolved
biological creatures we're
motivationally driven like we and we
have a pattern
we are not rational that's wrong now we
can learn to be
rational with great difficulty yeah but
fundamentally
and and maybe that's a tool but there is
underneath this
you said it was an ins an instinct so we
could take that apart a little bit so
the prefrontal cortex grew out of the
motor cortex
so the mortar cortex enables you to
engage in voluntary activity
the prefrontal cortex enables you to
abstractly represent
motor activity play it out in an avatar
like universe
and kill off stupid ideas before they
kill you
so we we've evolved to produce
hypotheses
test them through dialectic often
and dispense with those that don't work
and so we've we've staked ourselves
on that attempt and we've evolved to be
able to do that and science i believe is
a is the extension of that the practical
extension of that
the most so that's all the extension i
would argue yes it's well so
successful so far right so far we have
the time frame problem
yeah so on the apocalyptic end let me
ask you what you think of this so
we have a particular view of a hydrogen
atom now it's
very reductionistic right and you can
see the power of that because we
understand hydrogen atoms well enough to
make them
to turn them into bombs yeah but you i
you could also argue that
it's because of that it's because of the
limitations of that form of knowledge
that we were inclined to turn them into
bombs that
we separated the hydrogen atom from its
context
its broad broad broad context it enabled
us to manipulate a tiny fragment of
reality
to exclude the rest of reality from that
consideration that
bestowed upon us a tremendous power but
look what it produced it produced the
hydrogen bomb and
you know that could be evidence that the
theory
however practically useful
for producing deadly machinery was not
useful at all
at a larger scale of analysis and that
that's the
that's the paradox i guess of the
reductionistic approach
yeah i think it well you know it's kind
of like reminds me of the
of the sorcerer's apprentice the movie
with mickey mouse or whatever it was or
yeah i think mickey mouse yeah and um is
the sense that
it's it is a remarkable well or maybe
maybe i should
do spiderman with great power comes
great responsibility but but um
which may be a summary of your book but
anyway um
uh the we have this weird like i
i can't agree with you more we have this
jewelry dichotomy we've discovered
science
well the the scientific method was a
discovery it took a while to discover it
when the greeks didn't have it
they did a lot but if they'd been able
to know about empirical evidence they
would have done a lot more
um and so it was a discovery and it's a
discovery that was incredibly powerful
that works
but we humans you know um didn't
evolve and didn't evolve to discover the
scientific method i mean we had the
capability
and therefore we have all sorts of
evolutionary baggage
that makes us human and so we're on the
one hand have this incredible power by
using the scientific method
but on the other hand have the fact that
we are human
and we have all the slings and arrows
that came with being human all of the
evolutionary evolutionary positive and
negative features
of having developed a psyche as you
described it
one with you know i had a a a podcast
with uh joseph ledoux i don't know if
you know him
yeah we talked a great deal about fear
and the amygdala and
and how those things play out um but so
we have
we have this we have the people that are
manipulating this scientific method
who are who are subject to all of the
concerns that may you know
the jealousies the the the insecurities
and the wonder
all combined and somehow we have to
combine those to keep us
safe and and and secure and to make in
principle a better
again just saying we want a better
future for our children you're right
that's a fantasy too that's a
that's a that's a claim it doesn't have
to be why do we want to do that well for
some reason we think it's a good idea
um um maybe for some reason we believe
that there's such thing as better yeah
yeah and we and we quantify it and we
and again i would argue see to me i'm
i'm a solid empiricist if there's not an
empirical way of dis
of defining why it's better then it's an
irrelevant concept and that's why i have
i'm this just i'm a very pedestrian kind
of guy if you can't measure it
don't talk about it to some extent
right right and um and uh
and so but you can't measure it you
can't define it and then it's hard to
tell what the hell you're talking about
yeah yeah
then it just ends up being semantics
then it ends up being pure uh
intellectual masturbation you know which
is a lot yeah and you can shift
the concept around at your convenience
which is not helpful
which yeah and that's what sort of i
would argue much of post-modernism is
all about is that is that it's lost
track of what is real
and and it's just sort of intellectual
circles right so i i
i there's other questions about physics
i would like to ask you but i'm not
going to because we're running out of
time unfortunately but i will ask you
something
i'll ask you something instead that
comes out of what we've just been
discussing
so you just went on this panel at oxford
you said was it oxford it was the
oxford union debate yeah yeah okay so
and i know you're also interested in
social transformations and and what's
happening in the universities and you
described the crowd at oxford as woke so
i'm going to ask you i'm going to tell
you something i've been thinking about
i'd like you to tell me what you think
about it sure so
you know i was thinking for a long time
about the advantages of a
of a democratic monarchy like
great britain okay so imagine imagine
instead of executive legislative and
judicial
there's four branches of government okay
legislative judicial executive
and symbolic okay and so
you need it's helpful to have the queen
because then the president
isn't the queen yeah you're the
president that's the greatest thing
about a constitutional monarchy
you and i both have lived in canada and
the united states so that's i agree so
you can par
so so you might say that in a place
where there is no fourth branch of
government
the president the executive tends to
take on the symbolic weight of the king
yeah
okay we agree on that that's possible
anyways absolutely i think it's one of
the problems of american politics
yeah okay now i would say that's also
related to the problem of the separation
of church and state
and one of the things the west seems to
have got right
is the idea that we should render unto
caesar what is caesar's and render unto
god what is god's
well it's an analogous idea that's okay
you don't don't i'll just continue where
you going i need that to be described
more but okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah well imagine there's a
practical necessity for the separation
of the religious impulse from the
political impulse
but imagine that there's a psychological
necessity for that too
okay and then if if there aren't domains
specified
out for the different uh uh domains of
of
of practical thought political economic
religious
then they contaminate each other and
what happens is you don't get religious
rid of the religion you contaminate the
politics with it
okay and so i know i've been watching
what's been happening to richard dawkins
for example
yeah yeah right now richard's idea and
and and
i'm i'm an admirer of dawkins he can
think you know i mean he's brilliant
and i've read his books i understand
what he's doing and why
and i get his argument i think it's
incomplete for reasons we could get into
it
and probably will but i think there's
something missing there
and that is playing out is that when you
when you remove the
religious sphere and and you confuse it
with superstition
or you fail to discriminate between the
valid elements of it and the
superstitious elements
you don't get rid of the religious
impulse it goes somewhere else oh yeah
and i think we're go
if you're saying it's going into secular
religiosity now i well what do you think
i agree i mean what does it look like to
you no that's i i said that i've written
a p
i've written on it and i that was my
argument is that is that we're seeing
many of the aspects of religion being
manifest in
in secular arguments as someone pointed
out the only difference being
in unlike at least the christian
religion there's no possibility of
absolution
which is yeah yeah but that's not funny
yeah right that's
seriously not funny i know i know i
agree with you i know it's serious it's
not funny believe me i know it very well
i know you do i know but but that also
points out what a remarkable achievement
the idea of absolution is because
it's like the presumption of innocence
those two things those are miraculous
yeah well i uh constructs of thought
constructs of thought
i agree uh and i i you know i'm glad
we're having this discussion
one of the when you when you talked
about the symbolic i
one of the problems i sometimes have
with with you from having read you
in the past and we'll talk about this is
as you say things and i don't really
understand what they mean i mean they're
sufficiently i find them vague enough
that that that
i i really want them to know how you're
defining things and i've really enjoyed
great the fact that you've been defining
things and i think the
the the the the uh so i would agree with
you completely we have to realize
and i've had this discussion as you
probably know richard and i have had
discussions
on a lot there's a movie about us called
the unbelievers and we we spent a lot of
time
together and i think our views have
have come together in different ways
i would argue that religion on the whole
has not been a good thing
for people okay it's the first argument
but but in order to but we shouldn't
realize
we have to realize that in order that it
does serve an evolutionary purpose
if you want to call it purpose it's
there because it it has
it has sir it has survived all of
societies because it does
it meets some human needs in one way or
another
and therefore we have to ask what needs
does it
satisfy and realize what they are and
how can we
how can we provide them without the
fairy tales
so i guess we definitely do have to ask
that question and an extraordinarily
serious you know
one of the things that we would might
want to do if we can figure out how to
do it is also to have a discussion with
um roland griffith okay
do you know roland griffith's work not
as well as you obviously
okay well he's been investigating
psychedelics and yeah with psilocybin
yeah and he's a very solid scientist
i've heard people talk about so
yeah okay yeah yeah well there's there's
um there's a mystery there that's
virtually unfathomable and and and and
griffis is a very very solid scientist
and
and that's another place that would make
an interesting but it's it's relevant to
this point because
because there are i think the reason
that there has to be a religious domain
is because religious questions will
never go away
so even if you get rid of the answers
you can't get rid of the questions
oh i want but you never want to get rid
of the questions i would argue
that is with center that's my big
argument about everything is that we
have to encourage questioning
in fact that's what education should be
based on it should be based on answers
it should be based on questions
so i don't think wanting to i have no
desire to get rid of those questions
like
why if you want to call it why are we
here or why did yes i would argue the
why questions
ultimately however the difference may be
and i know richard has gotten involved
in this too because he wrote the forward
for one of my books but the
the why questions are really all how
questions
they only remain why questions if you
believe there's some fundamental purpose
and if you
and since there's no evidence of that
ultimately when you ask why are we here
really means how are we here
when you ask why does your heart pump
blood it doesn't mean that there's some
someone made per it means how does it
hot what are the biochemical processes
by which
you know your heart allows your body so
okay so all right so let let me respond
to that a bit and
i i understand your point and take it
very seriously and so
but what i've been looking at because i
do look at this biologically to begin
with
because i i i try to look at things
scientifically
in so far as the science allows those
things to be viewed okay
and so to the degree that i can look at
religious matters from a biological
perspective
i do that because it's simpler okay so
i believe that the religious instinct
manifests itself
in a variety of fundamental uh uh
motivations
but they're they're they're abstract
motivations to some degree so
the experience of awe that's a major one
the the experience of beauty that's
another one
the the experience of admiration
and the desire to imitate those are
those are crucial
and so so one of the things that i would
point out
you can tell me what you think about
this and i've been trying to formalize
this idea and i don't know
its extent so i look at christianity in
particular
although not uniquely christianity but
christianity in particular as
uh a thousands of years uh investigation
into the structure of the abstracted
ideal to imitate so imagine
we imitate those we admire okay but
we're abstract creatures so we want to
know what's
the essence of what should be imitated
itself now
we investigate that it's not all
explicit we have to
represent it in music we have to
represent it in art we have to represent
it in architecture
because we're we're we're hitting at it
from multiple different
domains and that is a reductionistic
argument right it says nothing to do
about divinity itself sure
it's purely it's purely psychological
biological argument
well where i look i where i would
disagree with you
and i like the way you've described it
in many ways but where i disagree with
you i guess would be
the word investigation my problem with
christianity
and i've said this you know i've debated
once at yale many years ago with the
uh the you know theology and and i've
argued
that and i've never i've argued with
theologians i've said
give me an example in the last four
hundred years
of a contribution of theology to
knowledge
and you know what they all say what do
you mean by knowledge
now what do you mean by theology well
okay maybe but but but i would argue
because i would point to nietzsche
yeah and yen young yeah yeah okay but i
would say if you are
asked a psychologist or a chemist or a
biologist
what contributions and all they list
these things but the point is that
my problem with christianity is it
stopped asking questions
it stopped being an investigation and it
was and it was it was a dictum
here's the answer yeah don't ask any
more questions and that is the
antithesis of
of what i exist for so i think that's
right look look factor analytic studies
of religion
reveal something like two factors
there's a dogmatic element
and there's a spiritual element and if
you if you do large-scale surveys of
people now you see that
their faith in the dogmatic element has
declined substantially but
their spiritual claims have not but but
again
i'd ask you i don't know whenever
someone uses the word spiritual for me
my mind kind of glazes over because i
have no idea what they're talking about
well no i think it's on the
investigative side that's why i brought
that up
because i think what you're objecting to
correct me again if i'm wrong but it's
the same thing that you object to as a
scientist
you object to dogma as
as de facto dogma
absolutely everything is a subject
question nothing is sacred
right right right so that's the
continued investigation of the creative
mind
yeah so now but but you know there
that's not that can't be quite right
either though because
when you move forward you always move
forward on the basis of dogma but you
question it like you do both at the same
time which is what you said people
should be doing
at the beginning because you do assume
the validity of your knowledge
to move forward until you hit an
impediment and then you question it
you have to sure you have to look you
have to make assumptions
to move forward you just the difference
between science and religion is
you can recognize later that the
assumptions are wrong and that's the
beauty that's what to me the distinction
between science and religion
we all make assumptions and in fact i'd
love to the term
i've often quoted from the x-files where
fox mulder says i want to believe
we all want to believe as a scientist i
want to believe that's why we're all
religious i argued
in that sense we all want to believe the
difference is science eventually has a
technique allows us to say yeah but that
belief was wrong
and and and and that's the beauty that's
what that's why i like science it works
in that sense
but we all have to make some hypothesis
but the willingness to dispense with it
even if it's central to our being
and that's what i say to everyone if an
education for everyone should exist
should be if it's at at its best should
comprise one thing
that at some point you find that
something that's central to your being
something you feel that's central to
your existence you find out to be wrong
because that is the liberation that
education should provide
and that's part of my problem with
humility isn't it yeah and that's part
of my problem with the
the getting back to the bookmarks is
that people aren't allowed to ask
questions
because right and that's that's that's
the antithesis of
knowledge yeah anyway so is that the
in is that the antithesis as well of the
true religious impulse
is is to question and search because you
don't look
israel israel means those who struggle
with god
right yeah it doesn't mean those who
have got god right
well yeah no i mean one of the reasons i
you know but it's again i i recognize
that part of the reason i feel this way
is because i was brought up i wasn't
brought up in a religious family but i
was still brought up in a jewish family
so it's natural to say hey there's nice
things about the jewish religion and one
of the things
that i like about jewish religion is
yeah you can question you can question
god
and uh and and and all of that but but
that doesn't make me think that but at
the same time
it's all still based on a ridiculous
fallacy
that doesn't make it any more legitimate
culturally i
i like the the cultural it's like genes
okay i like i like the expression the
cultural expression
but the underlying basis of judaism is
just as ridiculous
in fact just as ridiculous as evil as
vicious
as as as christianity and and and islam
and and most other religions
so i guess i i i like
the the the cultural manifestation so
yeah there are lots of cultural jews but
i don't even say that
i don't find myself as people say why
don't you define yourself as jewish now
and it's because well you know it
doesn't mean anything to me i mean maybe
from a from the fact that i was brought
up in a certain way but i
i try not to identify myself by you know
whether i'm canadian or american those
things aren't
aren't as important to me as what i'm
thinking and so
so um yeah i don't think strike it does
strike me that you are though
someone who's who's part of israel in
terms of the struggle
oh sure yeah yeah i mean it blew me away
when i realized when i knew when i found
out that that was what that word meant
it really
shocked me to the to my depths yeah well
it it does surprise association
i think yeah but i don't think you
should over sometimes i think you tend
to
it's a nice it's a nice discovery but
don't read into it more than it is
i mean you know after all the yahweh was
a word that you weren't allowed to say
i mean it's based it's based at the same
time as being based on questioning
it's also based on absolutes that you're
not allowed to disobey
and therefore it is evil in the sense
that every other religion is evil
because
there shouldn't be there shouldn't be
questions you can't ask there shouldn't
be words you can't use
whether it's yahweh or ginger if in my
in uh
look we should probably leave the rest
of this i would say because we had a
good discussion
and it's a really good place to end it
is a good place and we began
and i look forward to following this
it's really been
a true pleasure really and i think i
think i hope for me as well
we'll have found something in our two
hours of discussion if it's a science or
otherwise
to see that there's a lot more left to
discuss and i look forward
not just to my podcast but you know
having more chance maybe to discuss
publicly too it's been
it's been a real pleasure and great
great i really enjoyed it and
thank you very much thank you very much
i have many more questions for you but
they'll wait yeah all right great i'm
looking forward to when we meet again
good well thanks a lot it would be bad
if in two hours we
we got through everything yes yes yes
that would be so good
okay all right all right okay
you